hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar targeting the glyco immune
checkpoints siglics to enhance antiviral
innate immune functions I'm Susie Valdez
of lab roots and I will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labroots and brought to you by genscript
to learn more visit them at
genscript.com now we encourage you to
participate today by submitting any
questions you might have during this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send our speakers will answer any
questions via the email address you
provided at the time of registration and
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation I'd
now like to welcome our speaker today
Muhammad Abdel mohsen associate
professor at the vaccine and
immunotherapy Center in immunology
microenvironment and metastasis program
in the Ellen and Ronald Kaplan Center
Muhammad welcome to you you may now
begin your presentation
thanks for the introduction and um hi
everyone today I want to give you a
quick overview of some of the work we
are doing in our lab at the Western
Institute and in our lab we work in the
interface between the fields of
um just
sorry trying yeah sorry going back
trying in our lab we work in the
interface between the field of virology
Immunology
yeah not sure why
the sliders are not advancing correctly
but and and glycobiology and it's pretty
obvious why we need to study um
immunological function during viral
infection uh but I would like to start
but what is glycobiology and why should
we care
so
I usually like to start with this very
simple fact that is every single living
cell on Earth are covered with a heavy
layer of glycan sugar on their cell
surface and in the last few years there
is many advances in the field of
glycobiology that make it clear that is
these glycans are biologically active
molecules that can impact several
immunological functions during many
diseases including Cancers and in fact
there is many important works that's
being done on the cancer related to
glycobiology in the last few years as
you definitely need to check out it but
not as much in infectious diseases
including virology and that's why today
I want to give you an example of how
glycans can mitulate immunological
functions during viral infection and in
particular I will focus on something
called glyco immune Schick buoins and
I'm sure all of you are quite familiar
with classic immune negative Shake
points that are worked by protein
protein interactions so for an example
the protein bd1 expressed an immune
cells bind to another protein called
btl1 on surface of target cells
including cancer cells and this
interactions inhibit immune functions
and allow for an example cancer cells to
evade immune surveillance
now and and that's why this is obviously
a promising ways to enhance immunity
during cancer and other diseases so now
recently it become clear there is
another class of immune negative
checkpoints that work by binding Two
Sugars and that's why they call glyco
immune negative shig points so again let
me start this bar by telling you that is
every immune cell
Express several uh sugar binding
proteins are also called lectins on
their cell surface and The Binding
between some of those lectins expressed
on the immune cells and Civic or certain
sugar on the surface of target cells
plays very important role in the ability
of these
immune cells to recognize and Target
these target cells and that's why many
cancer cells many vitally infected cells
try to decorate themselves with specific
sugar in order to ensure binding to some
of those inhibitory lectins and evade
immune surveillance and obviously this
is representing in a good a good
possibility to block those glyco immune
negative Chic points to enhance immunity
so today I will give you I will focus on
one of those glyco immune negative Shake
points and I will very show you how this
glyco immune negative checkpoints
interactions can play an important role
in regulating innate immune functions
during HIV infection which is some of
this work was published in this paper uh
last year in this project that was led
by Samson adeniji a postdoc in our lab
and then after this I will show you how
the exact same glyco immune negative
checkpoints could be an important role
in modulating uh immunity against
sarskov-2 infection so start with the
first part on
um on HIV and before I get into how this
glyco immune negative checkpoint can
impact HIV immunity or immunity against
HIV I want to spend a quick minute
telling you why we still need to
understand immunological functions
during HIV infection despite the fact
that we currently have a very effective
antiretroviral therapy or also called
Art that can effectively suppress viral
replication
and the reason is that antiretroviral
therapy or art do not does not cure HIV
and despite how many years of therapy
there'll always be a large number of HIV
infected cells that possessed in the
blood and at multiple tissues in the
body and these cells can hide from the
immune system in a ways we don't
understand but because of those cells
regardless how many years in therapy
once is stopping it the virus to rebound
within a couple of weeks it doesn't
matter if the patient on therapy for
five years 10 years 15 years once a
stopping therapy the virus will rebound
very quickly
so a lifelong therapy is necessary for
those 37 million people living with HIV
worldwide including 2 million children
and now lifelong therapy is associated
with several uh problem I will just
highlight one of those problem now which
is the fact that his people living with
HIV regardless of viral suppression are
still suffering from high incidence of
many aging and inflammation Associated
diseases including neurological
impairments cardiovascular diseases
Cancers and whatnot now these diseases
happen at much higher rate and sometimes
at much lower age in hiv-infected
individuals compared to their HIV
negative counterparts so that's why
there is still a lot of interest in
finding a way of ways to enhance
immunity to eliminate these HIV infected
cells to cure HIV and prevent these
significant complications
so now this project started in our lab a
couple of years ago uh when we asked the
question do HIV infected cells have
different glycans on their cell surface
compared to HIV uninfected cells and
taking a long story short because this
was published in this paper a couple of
years ago we indeed found that is the
HIV infected cells have a glycomic
signature to them that
different than the glycomic signature on
the surface of HIV uninfect itself and
one of the features of this girl iconic
signature was an up regulation of the
sugar called Alpha 23 salic acid and
this was interesting for us because
Alpha 23 salic acid is a sugar ligand of
one of those glyco immune negative
cheekbones lectins I mentioned to you
and this one in particular called cyclic
ni so cyclic 9 is a sugar binding
protein that Express on the surface of
many immune cells including on a subset
of the cytotoxic in key cells and when
cyclic 9 expression and K cells uh bind
to alpha two-stricylic acid expression
target cells this binding
in send an inhibitory signal to the inky
cells and allow the target cells to
evade and key immune surveillance so now
knowing that this HIV infected cells do
have a high level of alpha 23 salic acid
on their cell surface we naturally ask
the question do cyclic nine salic acid
interactions contribute to the ability
of hiv-infected cells to evade and key
immune surveillance but before we even
attempt to answer this question we
wanted to do a very simple test we
reasoned that is if this in K cells
expressing cyclic nion this inhibitory
lectin cyclic nine Blaze any rule
whatsoever during HIV infection we
should see
a correlation in Vivo in Vision between
the percentage of this in key cell that
expresses inhibitory receptor cyclic 9
here in the x-axis imposed the top and
the bottom panels and level of HIV is a
level of HIV viremia in the Plasma on
individual when they are not on therapy
or Remnant HIV when the patient are in
Serbia and we reason that is we should
see a post of correlation right the more
in K cell that exhibition inhibitory
receptor the more virus more immune
inhibition more virus right makes sense
but to our surprise we found a negative
correlation in both cases which didn't
make any sense to us why more in case
out that except bracing and inhibitory
receptor to immune system to immune
function correlate negatively or with
correlate the more of it correlate with
less virus and at this point we thought
that is maybe just just a random in Vivo
correlation it's just a correlation
after all it doesn't show any causality
and maybe it's just a random correlation
that doesn't mean anything in Vivo and
we just decide to ignore it until this
Bieber came out where the authors
investigate the rule of the exact same
ink
subbulation that expressed signal canine
but now during Hepatitis B viral
infection and they also reported this
correlation in their paper uh between
cyclic the inky cell that Express
glickline and level of hepatitis B viral
DNA
and unfortunately the author didn't try
to explain this counter-intuitive
correlation but it striked Us and how
similar it is to what we found during
HIV again negative correlation and at
this point we thought that is maybe
these negative correlation actually real
maybe they do have a significant
biological meaning that is we just don't
understand what is this meaning and it
was at this point that it came to us
that is maybe we are confusing the
subpopulation that expressed cyclic 9
with a cyclic line now the cyclic line
the molecule itself is inhibitory there
is definitely inhibitory there is no
question about that but that doesn't
necessarily mean that is the NK
subbulation that expresses inhibitory
receptor are inhibited and are less
cytotoxin because the cytotoxicity of NK
cells is a balance between the
expression of several Inky activating
receptors and markers and several
inhibitory receptorism markers and it's
possible that is this in case of
population that expresses gluc9
regardless of their expression of cyclic
line are actually highly activated and
highly cytotoxic because maybe they do
Express high level of several Inky
activating receptors and markers and
maybe low level of other inhibitory
receptors and marker beside
regardless of cyclic line expression
which would actually explain our
negative correlation here
so we started to explore this
alternative hypothesis that is the
cyclic nine Boston in K cells are
actually more activated and more
cytotoxic against HIV infected cells
compared to the cyclic nine uh negative
subpopulation and we started exploring
this by simply
measuring uh the expression of several
Inky activating an inhibitory receptor
on the surface of cyclic line positive
cells here in solid Dot and comparing
them to compare to the expression on
cyclic line negative cells here in open
circles and we use the cells isolated
from either HIV uninfected individuals
HIV infected individual on therapy or
hiv-infected individual
not on therapy and as you can see here
the expiration of several Inky
activating receptors and markers
including CDC Christine cd38 nkb30
peripheral denam are higher on cyclic 9
positive cells compared to cyclic line
negative cells on the other hand the
expression of several important
inhibitory receptors to in K like nkg to
a digit are lower on cyclic nine
positive cells compared to cyclic 9
negative cells regardless of HIV disease
status so so far we know in Vivo that
these cells having an activated
phenotype
and
they do exhibit a negative correlation
with HIV all suggesting that these cells
are actually more activated and more
cytotoxic against HIV infected cells and
if you really think about that this is
not something very weird because uh
classic immune negative checkpoints like
bd1 are usually expressed and highly
activated highly differentiated T cells
that is they now need to express bd1
tourist terrain their High activation
and cytotoxicity so now we wanted to
explore if indeed cyclic line positive
cells are more cytotoxic against HIV
infected cells compared to cyclic 9
negative which is we use different
approaches in order to answer this
question in one of the approach we just
simply deplete cyclic line positive
cells from NK as you can see here total
ink will have about 40 percent of the
cells expressing cyclic nine we can
nicely deplete this cyclic nine Buster
subpopulation and then we use the wall
in K cell that contained cyclic 9
subpopulation and the cyclic line
depleted in key cells in a killing
assays against hiv-infected cell lines
obviously at the same effector to Target
ratio with the idea if cyclic 9 positive
in key cells plays an important rule in
killing HIV infected cells we should see
a reduction in the killing of
hiv-infected cells when we use a cyclic
line depleted in K cells which is indeed
what we see here you can see when we
measure inkey the granulation or
cytotoxist using two different assays
LDH release and and
cfse red assay you can see the total
Inky cells here in blue can degranulate
and kill hiv-infected cells better than
cyclic nine the cyclic nine depleted
Inky cells here in yellow
kind of indirect evidence that is indeed
cyclic nine positive cells are more
cytotoxic against HIV infected cells
compared to cyclic 9 negative cells
which is something we want Nicos to
directly evaluate by sorting cyclic 9
negative in K cells from cyclic 9
positive in K cells and then co-culture
them with hiv-infected cell lines and as
you can see here in the left panel the
cyclic 9 bostif in K cells are indeed
more cytotoxic compared to the cyclic 9
negative in K cells toward hiv-infected
cells and in the left side that is
confirmed when we look at the
degranulation of these cells and indeed
again the cyclic line positive increase
cells can degranulate more
toward hiv-infected cells compared to
the cyclic 9 negative in K cells so we
know so far that is indeed the cyclic
line negative positive in K cells are
more activated in Vivo and More
cytotoxic in vitro compared to the
cyclic line negative in K cells which is
consistent with our with the negative
correlation we see with HIV and Vivo but
then the question Nick is what about
their expiration of cyclic line yes this
this in case cells expressing cyclic 9
are more cytotoxic against HIV but is
that possible that is their expiration
of the inhibitory receptor cyclic 9 is
still risk to rain in their high-sided
toxicity and if we were to block cyclic
9 we can even unleash a higher
cytotoxicity from these cells against
HIV infected cells and the answer is yes
we when we made a blocking antibody for
cyclic nine with uh help of Gene script
and we used this blocking antibody
in a co-culture assays against
hiv-infected cells using total Inky
cells we can indeed dramatically enhance
ability of these Inky cells to kill HIV
infected cells and this antibody which
is specific for cyclic 9 because if we
now do this experiment but instead of
using total in key cells we use a cyclic
9 depleted in key cells the antibody do
not have any effect because there is no
target cells for it this experiment was
done using a cell lines infected with
HIV but we could also recapsulate this
data using autologous assays where we
isolate bbmcs uh from uh
individuals and we isolate CD4 from
those bbmcs and fix them with HIV and in
the same time we isolate Inkay from the
same donors and then we co-culture those
hiv-infected CD4 T cells T cells and in
K cells in the presence or absence of an
isotype control or the cyclic line
blocking antibody and then we can do
different measurements we can look for
the effect of the cyclic line blocking
antibody on the inky degranulation and
as you can see here indeed the blocking
antibody uh significantly enhance the
ability of the inky cells to the
granulate against HIV infected cells we
can look for the amount of hiv-infected
cells
remaining and you can see that is the
blocking antibody compared to the
isotype control can cause a reduction in
the level of HIV infected cells we can
take the cultural supernatant from those
culture and try to infect new cells and
you can see this is a culture
supernatant from the culture in the
presence of the
cyclic nine blocking antibody here in
red
can lead to less infection compared to
the isotype control in Gray or the no
antibody in blue
so now from this part we know or we can
summarize that is we found that a
surprisingly that is this in K cell
that Express this inhibitory receptor
cyclic line are actually highly
activated and highly cytotoxic again is
virally infected cells and that is maybe
due to their High expression of several
Inky activating receptors and markers
like nkp30 the nap and lower expression
of other inhibitory receptors like nkg
to a compared to the cyclic line
negative NK cells however we also found
that the Z Z cell expiration of cyclic 9
is terrorist training their full
cytotoxicity and if we were to block
this in interaction we couldn't unleash
even a higher side toxicity against
virally infected cells from this already
highly cytotoxic in K cells and the next
question for us was now we know that
there's a cyclic line cialic acid
interaction do play a rule in the
ability of HIV infected cells to evade
Inky immune surveillance the next
equation can we design a selective
approach to break these cyclic nine
salic acid interaction in order to
enhance the susceptibility of
hiv-infected cells to intimidated
clearance and we reasoned that is we can
use this enzyme called salidis Society
is as an enzyme that is can cut cyalic
acid from the surface of cells can cut
salic acid including alpha-2-3 salic
acid and however if we were to use cell
LEDs this will just cut cyalic acid from
the surface of HIV infected cells and
HIV uninfected cells so we borrowed a
great idea in the cancer field that is
was done by Karen burritosi and other to
conjugate these solidase to an antibody
and for our case we reason that is if we
conjugate salidase to an hiv-specific
antibody the idea here that is the
hiv-specific antibody will steer the
salidase to the surface of HIV infected
cells cutting cyclic acid only from the
HIV infected cells without it impacting
HIV infect uninfected cells so now
cutting the cyalic acid from the surface
of HIV infected cells will enhance their
susceptibility to in key mediated
clearance without impacting the surface
of HIV uninfected cells and indeed when
we produce those HIV antibody again with
the help of genescribe and then
conjugate them to cilidase which is a
work of uh uh our colleague can hands
you in Rice University
and when and then we tested the ability
of this conjugate to remove cyalic acid
from the surface of HIV infected cells
but not HIV uninfected cells so what we
did is we mix it HIV infected cells here
in this Factor plots in the right and
HIV uninfected cells in the left and the
both type of cells were in the same tube
and then we stain them for cyclic acid
here in the y-axis and when we treated
these cells with a small concentration
of
um uh the conjugates and in this case we
use an antibody called nih4546 which is
hiv-specific antibody and we conjugate
them with the solidase we use 25
nanomole and you can see here even at
this lower concentration the level of
cyalic acid is reduced dramatically from
the surface of HIV infected cells but
not HIV uninfected cells we can increase
the concentration of the conjugate and
you can see a nice dose dependent
reduction on the level of celic acid
from the surface of HIV infected cells
but not from the surface of HIV
uninfected cells so we know there is
some specificity to the uh to the
conjugate and removing cyalic acid only
from the surface of HIV infected cells
and the next obvious question does that
lead to potentiating Inky killing
against these cells and we tested that
again using different models and I'm
here showing you one example when again
we cultured or mixed HIV uninfected
cells here in red and we dyed them with
a red color or HIV infected cells and we
dye them with a green color and you can
see that here with this life Imaging
staining or also the number of the cells
in this bar graphs
then we added to those cells Inky cells
isolated from HIV infected individuals
and you can see the NK will start
killing HIV infected cells you can see
in a about two two-fold reduction in the
level of HIV infected sounds uh compared
to the control with no impact on the HIV
uninfected cells here in red we can add
an isotope control and nothing much
happens we can add an hiv-specific
antibody at two different concentration
and you can see the two-fold reduction
in the level of HIV infected cells
became five or six-fold reduction
because those antibody will elicit
antibody mediter cytotoxicity and you
can clearly see that is in the the level
of HIV infected cells dramatically
reduce and you wonder if there is even a
space for the conjugate to reduce this
further and indeed this when we add the
same concentration of Z conjugate
instead of the antibody you can see the
five six fold reduction become from 25
to 50 full reduction and you can barely
see any HIV infected cells in the
culture and most importantly with very
minimal impact if if if there is impact
at all on HIV uninfected cells in red
again this experiment was using cell
line infected with HIV and we could
recapsulate the same result using
autologous system primary cell where we
infect CD4 T cells and co-culturalism
with bbmcs from the same individuals in
the presence or absence of the antibody
or the antibody conjugates and we can
again measure two different things
either increase the granulation either
as acceleration of cd1 cd107 or
coexpression between c1o7 and interferon
Gamma or cd-107 and tnf Alpha and in all
of those cases you can see that there's
two different concentration of the
conjugates here in bright red can lead
to higher in KD granulation compared to
the exact same true concentration of the
antibody alone here in dark red and
obviously this resulted in a reduction
in the level of HIV infected cells when
using this conjugates again in bright it
compared to the antibody alone in
Darkrai so just to summarize this part
and just as this is just a quick example
of how studying glycobiology could allow
us to identify a novel glyco immune
Schick buoying mechanism that may be
exploited by HIV infected cells and I
will show you how that might be also
true for other bodily infected cells to
evade immune surveillance and how this
information was actually useful and
allowed us to develop a proof of concept
approach to selectively enhance a
susceptibility of HIV infected cells to
immune mediated clearance by using this
salidase HIV specific antibody
conjugates which is now we obviously
advancing to animal studies but that is
will lead me to the second part of my
presentation which is a question is this
is specific for HIV or is this cyalic
acid cyclic interaction could also
contribute to the ability of other
virally infected cells to evade immune
surveillance which is obviously I will
focus on sarskov-2 Infected cells and
the work I will show you Nick is is uh
is is is uh work of Brit massini another
postdoc in our lab
and probably all of you know that his
severe covid-19 is associated with
several alterations to the profile of
many immune cells in our body including
alteration to the profile of Inky cells
this has been shown in several
publication but it's unclear whether
this alteration can cause uh alteration
to the functions of these NK cells this
NK cells expressing different markers
but that mean that is the inky functions
during severe covid-19 are impaired and
as all of you know Inky cells can either
kill directly by direct side toxicity
making a direct synapse between the inky
cells and infected cells or they can
bind to the FC portion of uh
antigenous specific antibody in order to
make another synapse that this will
allow them to kill by something called
antibody dependency or cytotoxicity or
ADCC so it's not clear of these
anti-sarskov-2 Inky function either
direct excited toxicity or ADCC are
impaired during severe covid-19 18 and
what host Factor might delete these
functions so we first wanted to answer
this question whether this alteration
lead to reduction in the functions so we
collected samples from source code to
negative controls so an individual with
mild covid-19 or hospitalized covet 19.
and first we confirmed what is known in
the literature that is indeed the NT
cells in those individuals with
hospitalized covid-19 have different
alterations they do Express lower cd16
higher cd57 higher second several other
alterations so we know that is these
individual we collected are
representative of what is going on in
the literature Nick is we wanted to ask
if these cells in key cells have lower
functionality so we did that by either
culture this bpmc is from those negative
mild or hospitalized covid-19 patient by
themselves or co-culture them with a
target cells a cell line that is
expressing sarskov 2 Spike protein
we did this culture also between the
bbmcs and the target cells in the
presence uh or absence of an antibody
that is not specific for sarskov 2 or
sarskov 2 specific antibody in order to
evaluate edcc
and then we left this culture for 16
hours and then we measure in key the
granulation at the marker of Inky
functionality in order to measure that
excited toxicity we just subtracted the
inky degranulation we get from the
co-culture between the bbmcs and the
target cells to the bbmcs alone in order
to measure edcc we subtracted the uh
degranulation we're getting when we use
an antibody specific for sarskov 2 from
the culture when we use an antibody
non-specific for sarskov 2 after
normalizing both condition to the bbmc's
control
so indeed as we hyperfide that is this
alteration are indeed associated with
less functionality this Inky cells from
individuals with hospitalized covid-19
are less capable of degranulating as
measured by the co-expression of cd107
interferon Gamma or uh site or releasing
cytokine like interferon Gamma or
co-expression of interferon gamma and
tnf Alpha compared to the inky cells
isolated from the mild or negative uh or
source of two negative individual and
that is uh in the case of direct
cytotoxicity this is also true for ADCC
these cells are less capable of
eliciting ADCC compare when they are
isolated from hospitalized covid-19
patient compared to individuals with
mild covid-19 or sarskov-2 negative
individuals we also measure the level of
how much virus in the blood in those
individual by measuring the level of in
antigen and as you can see here in the
x-axises the ability of the NK cells to
either elicit direct cytotoxicity and
degranulated negatively correlate with
how much virus in the body so it's a
more the less Inky functionality the
more virus
so now we know that is the NK cells from
hospitalized covid-19 patients are
indeed less capable of eliciting such
anti-source code to direct cytolytic and
edcc activity compared to stinky from
control we ask if the question does
cyalic acid cyclic interaction
contribute to this list functionality
and as we found during HIV infection we
indeed also found that it's a cyclic 9
positive in K cells here in solid
thoughts are capable of eliciting higher
ADCC compared to the cyclic line
negative NK cell so they are also highly
cytotoxic against sarcoph2 sounds you
can see that when we use cells from
negative mild hospitalized that is a
cyclic line positive in key cells here
in solid dots capable of eliciting
higher edcc compared to the cyclic 9
negative in key cells when we measure
cd1070 granulation same true when we
measure cytokine release interferon
gamma tnf Alpha again these cells are
capable of degranulating and releasing
cytokine better than the cyclic 9
negative control even when we measure
also uh degranulation plus cytokine
release we get the same message when we
then correlate the ability of the cyclic
line Buster for cyclic 9 negative cells
to elicit either direct cytotoxicity or
edcc and level of virus antigen in the
body we found that is there is no uh the
the ability of cyclic line negative and
cyclic line positive cells to illicit
ADCC do correlate negatively with
um with the in antigen but without
difference between the cyclic 9 negative
and cyclic line positive but when we
focus in edcc we found that there's a
cyclic line positive cells ability to
degranulate or release cytokine
correlate negatively with how much
antigen only in the acyclic nine Buster
cells but not in the cyclic line
negative cells such just think that
there's a cyclic nine bust of cells are
playing an important role in the ADCC
activity against cyclic 9.
and next we then also ask us the
question do these cells have an
activated and mature phenotype during
sarskov 2 as we observe it during HIV
and the answer is yes we indeed found
that there's a cyclic nine positive in K
cells again here in solid dots are
expressing high level of CDC Christine
which is again important marker for
eliciting ADCC compared to cyclic 9
negative cells again regardless of
disease status these cells are more
mature they are expressing cd57 which is
a maturation marker compare to cyclic 9
negative cells they do Express high
level of nkg to C which is an activating
markers and they do Express lower level
of nkg to a which is an inhibitory
marker so similar to what we found
during HIV these cells are more
activated and more cytotoxic against uh
uh um HIV and sarskov-2 infected targets
uh compared to
um cyclic 9 negative cells and again the
next equation these cells is still
except cyclic line and if we were to
block this interaction against again
using a cyclic line blocking antibody
that's again we use the help of genus
crypto making can we enhance the
anti-sarce to edcc activity and as you
can see here compared to an isotype
control when we use a cyclic line
blocking antibody we can see an increase
in several marker of degranulation and
cytokine release cd-107 cd107
coexpression with interfield Gamma or
tnf alpha or even tnf alpha x
suppression or coexpression between tnf
Alpha and interfield and Gamma that is
the cyclic line blocking antibody could
enhance the ability of those cells to
degranulate but the next question is
this degranulation is actually equal to
lysing the cells so we use this
targeting killing assay when we have a
target cells expressing source of two
Spike protein and these cells have one
part of luciferase and the media have
the other part of the luciferase so we
co-culture this within K cells in the
presence of uh
anti-sarskoff II Spike antibodies and
the idea is when the cells are being
lysid the part of the luciferase inside
the cells will go to the outside the
cells bind with the other part and we
can measure the civilizers by luciferous
activation and the idea here is we when
we do that without cyclic nine blocking
antibody we see some level of killing
but the hypothesis if we were to block
cyclic 9 using the cyclic line blocking
antibody we can even lead to higher uh
cellulitises that is we can measure by
luciferase so we examine if that is true
and the answer is absolutely this is
true when we use an anti-cyclic line
blocking antibody we can enhance the
license of the source of two specific
target cells by ADCC so again going back
to this model similar to what I showed
you is HIV
in this model we also found that there's
a cyclic line bust of cells are indeed
highly activated and highly cytotoxic
against sarskov2 so it's not just as
specific for HIV and can be applicable
for many other viral infection and that
is again probably due to their High
expression of several Inky activating
markers and receptor like inkish g2c and
lower expression of inhibitory receptor
like nkg2a compared to cyclic line
negative in T cells however again we
found that there's a cyclic line salic
acid interaction is still restraining
this cytotoxicity and if we were to use
a blocking antibody for cyclic 9 we can
enhance the in case cytotoxicity against
sarcos to inflict itself so this is just
one quick example actually with how
glycans could be important for immunity
against HIV or mean virally infected
cells but again in the last few years
there is many advances in this field of
glycobiology and there is many areas
that is we uh in this advances we can
learn more about viral host interactions
and if you want to learn more about that
I will refer you to the several review
article and several people we write in
several uh direction that is we can
learn from the recent advances of
glycobiology in order to better
understand viral host interaction
against HIV against sarskov 2 and
perhaps against many other viral
infection and with that I would like to
go to my acknowledgment slides first and
foremost thanking all of the volunteer
participants in our
different studies uh thanking different
folks in our lab who did the work
um our collaborator with and without
outside Western our funders and thank
you for your attention and I will be
happy to take any questions
and thank you Muhammad we appreciate
that presentation and would you do us a
favor and go ahead and refresh your
screen at the top left because you were
not um you were frozen during the part
of your presentation and while you are
refreshing I just want to welcome our
audience to the Q a portion of the
webinar and if you have any questions
you want to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
so let's get started Muhammad it looks
like we already have some great
questions coming in and thank you so
much for refreshing
our first question is
since
um in addition to siglex are there any
other glycol immune checkpoints that had
been reported with antiviral or
anti-tumor immunity
yeah definitely for anti-tumor as I
mentioned there is a lot of great
workers being done in this area for in
the cancer field so there's many other
um
lectins that this could play a very
important role during cancers including
selectance which is bind to specific
kind of cause there is also DC cyan
um
galactins are very important immunity I
mean immunomodulatory lectins and again
there is many different paper showing
that is many of those LinkedIn and their
interactions could negatively or
positively impact uh immunity in
different ways in a way that this can
impact cancer but they also can impact
virally infected virally infected cells
we have also published paper and
galactins we have working on selectins
but as I mentioned uh this is like an um
non-necessary very many stream science
there is an evolving field rapidly and I
think we will see even more and more in
the next few years and the important
laws or rule of glycan that is usually
neglected in modular dating immunity
during both cancer and infectious
diseases
thank you so much now since
humor immunity and antiviral immunity
are two different checking scenarios do
you develop the antibody specific to
each scenario or just one
well I think the important part because
those salic those sorry glycans are very
abundant they are in every cell in our
body so the main challenge is to how to
get specificity and that's why we for an
example in our example on HIV we wanted
to conjugate conjugate salaries to
hiv-specific antibody to ensure that is
we are interrupting this interaction
only on the surface of HIV infected
cells because salic acid cyclic are
important for immunity so if you were to
block them non-specifically you might
get non-specific reaction like
inflammation autoimmunity so I think it
will be very important to try to be
adding a specificity to your antibody
either by making them buy specific try
specific antibody that is a go and
Target only your virally infected cells
or your cancer cells without impacting
your healthy cells so if if that will be
the goal you will probably your anti the
the cyclic antibody part will be the
same but you will need to add something
to it to infer specificity
um which is would be different between
tumor and virus and between different
viruses
thank you Muhammad and I want to thank
our audience for these great questions
our next question have you confirmed
that siglex9 ligands are expressed on
SARS CO2 cov2 or infected cells
yes yes so do the
not from we we confirmed that using
these cells we are using in our assays
but we did not do that using actual
cells infected we didn't have an access
to that like you know
um real cells infected that's a cells we
infect in vitro or we are or do Express
a sarskov 2 Spike and we use them in our
killing assays those cells do have the
cyclic nine ligand but obviously it will
be important to know if the actual cells
in the body the lung cells uh that do
Express uh that do are naturally
infected with sarskov 2 to express Alpha
two three salic acid many cells most
cells in the body will Express Alpha two
three salicylic acid is not something
specific to virally infected cells but
the question will be do they express it
more we could find that during our HIV
studies because obviously we can isolate
easily T cells from the blood and
examine their glycolm but obviously for
source of 2 that will be a much
challenging task because we will need
cells from the lung that is we know
infected with source of 2 and and
whatnot which is something we haven't
done
thank you Muhammad and how do you
connect those sigelect checkpoints from
anti-tumor immunity to antiviral
immunity
yeah such an interesting question so in
our studies we keep being surprised and
how
viruses seems to employ same or very
similar uh ways to evade immune
surveillance similar to cancer so in the
cancer field it is known for a long time
that is cancer cells uh have high level
of cyalic acidons are cell surface or
something called hyper cellulation they
do intentionally Express high level of
cyalic acid in order to ensure binding
to cyclic and evade immune surveillance
so we were so bright that is many viral
viral infection do the same thing they
do in they do Express they when they
infects the cells they find a way to
increase the level of cyalic acid on
their cell surface in order to uh again
maybe evade immune surveillance with
many cancer cells do Express the ligand
of another important lectin called
selecting because that helps them to
disseminate to move from the blood to
the tissues which is important for the
cancer cells to to metastasized we found
also that is virally infected cells can
enhance the ligand of silicon which is
called salal Lewis X which helps cells
to migrate so
obviously we don't have a a very clear
evidence but from our different studies
we keep finding that is there might be a
very shared mechanism of how both cancer
and virally infected cells take
advantage of the you know regular cell
biology because salic acid cyclic
interaction which is not there for
cancer to evade immune surveillance or
for vitally infected cells to even
immune surveillance it does have a very
important rule in controlling
inflammation and autoimmunity in the
body silicon interaction are not there
for again virally infected cells or
tumor to disseminate between tissues
they are there to help immune cells to
move to the site of inflammation but
somehow both cancer cells and virally
infected cells could hijack those
systems for their benefit and again we
keep finding that is both tumor and
virally infected cell seems to use share
the mechanism and that's why we
sometimes you know learning from the
cancer field and apply to virally
infected cells and vice versa because of
this potential shared mechanism
thank you so much and what type of
carbohydrate recognize the lectin and
what lectin do you use
yes depends on the lectins our body have
many lectins tense of lectins and each
one of those lectins do have a specific
uh glycan binding specificity and it's
not 100 clear actually but we know for
an example as I mentioned ciglex usually
bind to salic acid there are many
cyclics uh I think it's up to 16 cyclics
and they are different between mice and
human each one of those cyclics can buy
into a specific kind of salic acid
because not all salic acids are the same
silicon there are three of them
deselecting iselect and ill-selecting
and again they bind to specific kind of
focusylated glycans and so on and so off
so
um uh uh so the the different different
lectin do have different glycan or
carbohydrate recognition and those are
the ones inhuman mice will have
different lectin with different glycan
recognition glands will have their own
lectin with lectin recognition and
actually the plant lectin are very
commonly used in the field of
glycobiology in order to measure glycans
because their glycan specificity is
relatively well understood we use
different lectins in our study depends
on the uh project and the goal
thank you so much now we have time for a
couple more questions how specific is
Sailor days in eliminating the salic
acid
ligand that cyclic 9 recognizes and this
is a two-part question what can we find
Elf uh where where can we find Alpha two
three celic acids in our body and our
tissues or any particular cell types
yeah so the salad is will not be
specific to the cyclic line cyclic nine
ligand in particular salidis will just
remove cyclic lion
from a cyalic acid for all talic acid
when we test it it does take all Alpha 2
seric Acid but it will also take the
salic acid from other ligand and that's
why it was very important to conjugate
that to hiv-specific antibody because if
we wouldn't do that you would just
remove oxalic acid from HIV uninfected
cells we reason that is removing
alsoilic acid from HIV infected cells
from the surface of HIV infectances
might be good might be even better than
try to Target Alpha to suicylic acid in
particular because there are other
cyclics like cyclic seven also can help
these cells to evade and key immune
surveillance by using salidase you
remove the ligand of cyclic nion sigilic
7 other cyclic which is again will not
be something recommended if you will not
conjugate these salaries two of the
hiv-specific antibody because again
doing that you will lose your body a lot
of inflammatory checkpoint you might
cause inflammation but when we use that
when we conjugate that to HIV specific
uh antibody removing all kind of
salicylic acids from HIV infected cells
could be good because it can initiate
multiple immune system immune uh cells
against this again is the cells but the
salidase will not be specific and for
the second part where we can find Alpha
2 Series everywhere everywhere in the
body will have Alpha two three salic
acid is abundant our study just started
by the fact that his HIV infected cells
have higher level of it but many places
many cells will have uh will have Alpha
two three salic acid usually
in the body
one of the most areas that have a lot of
sciatic acid sorry a lot of sugars in
general are the gut and the gut
epithelial cells because these glycans
plays a very important role in
communication with the microbiome the
microbiome like to cut this sugar and
eat it and so you will find the gut the
lung or heavily glycosylated probably
the gutter the most glycosylated area in
the body but as I mentioned earlier in
the presentation every single cell on
Earth
without exclusion there are some cells
that do not have nucleus but they will
still have a glycom just showing you how
important having a glycan is as in a
kind of like an essence of living uh but
uh but obviously different cells will
have more or less of different kind of
salic acid and I'm not sure to the best
of my knowledge that is categorized yet
thank you so much now we have time for
one more question are cyclic 7 ligands
also expressed on each IV infected cells
as cyclic 7 is an inhibitory receptor on
NK cells and cyclic 7 expression
correlates with other activation
receptors
yeah that's a great question so indeed
it's a Glock 9 cyclic seven ligand will
be expressed on uh hiv-infected cells
again it's not 100 clear the ligand of
each cyclic it's believed that is cyclic
nine except by cyclic nine bind to Alpha
two three salic acid while cyclic seven
combine to Alpha two eight some people
say Alpha 26 and obviously Alpha two
eight and Alpha 2 6 will be expressed on
the regular cells as well in HIV
infected cells uh we have looked at
cyclic seven and we didn't find that is
the the cyclic seven
the percentage of cyclic Civic
suppressing cells correlate with HIV as
the cyclic nine positive cells do
correlate
um but however this was hard because
single exception exhibition mini in key
cells almost all uh cd56 dim in case
cells will Express the Glock 7 while
only in a sub uh population of those
will Express cyclic lines so all of the
cyclic line will also Express cyclic
seven but we did some analysis uh to
show that it was a cyclic nion more than
the cyclic seven contribute to the HIV
infected cells to even immune
surveillance now this is for HIV
infected cells when we use cancer cell
line that is quite different where the
cyclic seven but not the cyclic 9 is
more important to the cancer so
everything I show it to you is more
about viral infection and as I mentioned
while there are similarities between
cancer cells and vitally infected cell
files there is obviously also a very
clear differences and that is one of the
differences we found that the cyclic 7
to be more important against cancer
cells while cyclic line seems in our
analysis in Bose HIV and sarskov 2 that
is maybe playing in a more important
role during viral infection but again
that doesn't need to be more or better
studies uh better studied uh to to be
certain
Muhammad I want to thank you for your
presentation today would you like to
provide any closing remarks to our
audience before we go
now as I mentioned this is just what I
presented is just one quick example of
how glycan and glycan lectin interaction
could contribute to vital infection but
I I I do encourage people to just look
for our uh recent uh reviews and papers
because we study different angles on how
they mentioned the recent advances in
the field of glycobiology which is like
emerging field can allow us to better
understand vital host interaction and
while in this reviews and in this Bieber
we use either HIV or sarskov 2 or we
focus on HIV or sarskov to many of the
ideas and the concept we
um we we discuss and those reviews on
Bieber I believe could be applicable to
many other viral infection and I think
this will be in a great opportunity for
the viral feel to take advantage of this
recent advances in this field of
glycobiology thank you
I want to thank you again Muhammad for
your time today and for your important
research and before we go I'd like to
thank labroots and our sponsor jenscript
for underwriting today's educational
webcast and before we go I want to thank
our audience for joining us today and
further interesting questions and
questions that were submitted during the
live broadcast and those submitted
during the on-demand period that were
not addressed will be addressed by our
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration and
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone and bye-bye thanks